and the thing is I know as a viewer the
minute I start getting confused I check
out of the movie emotionally I'm
confused I think an audience has like
this you know like almost like
umbilical cord to the to the screen and
it gets severed when when confusion
comes and therefore you lose them
exactly and the thing is most of the
time when you get confused when I get
confused and that's severity is
basically because I'm not supposed to be
confused that's like it's a mistake
however there's no problem with being
momentarily confused if you feel you're
in good hands all right and I don't
think my movie and and disagree if you
please I don't think Pulp Fiction for
all of it's going in and around
yeah and how it goes in this big circle
I don't think it's hard to watch at all
you have to watch it I I ask for you to
watch it you can like put this on video
and like do the New York Times crossword
puzzle and watch the movie that's right
all right I'll ask you put everything
down and watch it and then once you do
that then you know you can follow it
it's easy to follow